just in the past few minutes the
Washington Post has moved a piece that
says the CIA concludes Saudi Crown
Prince ordered Jamal cushaw B's
assassination the Saudi journalist
killed in the Saudi consulate in
Istanbul if true and we haven't
independently confirmed this one would
think there's a lot of pressure on the
administration to have some kind of
different answer John yeah I think there
is I imagine the Donald Trump is having
an interesting conversation with Mike
Pompeo about all of this and I think it
should prompt a different approach to
the way we've been dealing with the
Saudis this was so obviously a planned
assassination from the top levels of
power in in Saudi Arabia and you can't
say we just have to protect our
interests and define our interests
solely as arms sales we have other
interests including the the you know the
rule of law on the idea that you're not
supposed to murder journalists who are
inconvenient quickly Susan yeah I agree
not a surprised but certainly puts
pressure on the administration to do
more than it's done to respond to this
yeah I totally concur with the two of
them and I think it is it's almost time
to relook at our Middle East policy you
know writ large I mean we're continuing
to see just you know thousands of people
still out of Syria still can't get into
their homes no resolution there and as
we sort of pivot to China and Russia
from a national security perspective
it's time to rethink our entire strategy
in the Middle East